it doesn't make any sense to have a
woman in Mormon underwear on the cover
of Sports Illustrated know one thing
Norman women can't be exactly and it
also doesn't make any sense to have a
woman in the in a bikini on the cover of
Sports Illustrated
fabric nobody's saying women can't wear
Mormon underwear nobody's saying women
can't wear bikinis but for us to pretend
that this is some empowering feminist
thing that should be celebrated that's
the lie may I give you another fire
analogy that is from Bill Maher he talks
about how liberals for some reason or
lefties the house is burning down and
instead of figuring out how to get out
which is what you're describing they're
going there's a dust bunny in the corner
over there and we better fight about how
to clean up the dust bunny and the whole
house is going to burn down and then you
just got a bunch of people with a lot of
rubble on top of them that's so good
it's just like another version of what
you just said there that's exactly it
the infighting the infighting instead of
going guys we got a bigger problem here
hooey yes absolutely 100% behind that
analogy - and that's that's something
I'd like if we talked about feminism for
example we're fixated on like are our
air conditioners sexist is can we build
chairs so that men can't man spread yeah
you know what I mean like we're
concerned about all of these little
things and it's like okay but like how
about these women over here that are
being thrown in prison because they want
to wear what they want to wear I mean or
these women over here they just want to
drive a car or these women you know I'm
bigoted yeah thank you but what's the
bigotry though right isn't that the
bigotry that's the bigotry that straight
is you're saying I don't care about
those women over there in fact it's
empowering for them to cover themselves
up head to toe in black in the you know
searing heat of the desert that's great
for them not for me for me I want to go
free the nipple but for them it's
empowering for them to cover themselves
in a fact let's celebrate that and let's
put a head jab on barbie and let's put a
swoosh on a jab and let's put on the
cover of Sports Illustrated
the part that makes you crazier than
anything else because when you see this
literally you know they'll have
everything you just described Nike that
has the job and the whole thing but like
they would never do that for Mormon
women or where is the you know you know
Orthodox Jewish women wear like a wig
where's the wig with the logo and like
all of these were like in any other
religious sense people would be like
this is bananas yeah no one's saying
that women shouldn't be allowed to do
these things no one's saying they
shouldn't be allowed to wear what they
want but sort of like the corporate give
me I was gonna say I was gonna say
saying that was gonna who's gonna be a
gross sexual reference I just the
corporate need to like yeah suck this
thing off yeah yeah yeah yeah no
absolutely I mean it doesn't make any
sense to have a woman in Mormon
underwear on the cover of Sports
Illustrated know one thing Mormon women
can't be at leats exactly and it also
doesn't make any sense to have a woman
in the in a bikini on the cover of
Sports Illustrated very nobody's saying
women can't wear Mormon underwear
nobody's saying women can't wear bikinis
but for us to pretend that this is some
empowering feminist thing that should be
celebrated that's the lie that's the
problem right there do that part of it
is just for the average person like
let's try to give these people like as
much credit as possible the average
advertising executive out there like
every commercial now that you see
there's always a woman in a job in it
you know it literally Reese's Pieces
yeah we all like Reese's Pieces and I'm
gonna buzz lemon with Reese's Pieces
okay yeah it's great antastic
but they do this in all these
commercials now and I don't for me it's
like I of course that's wonderful that
everyone can eat Reese's Pieces and
everyone can play sports we love it but
they do it because it's their way of
because they think inclusivity is the
number one thing and how else could you
show inclusivity as opposed to just
showing people like so like they think
they're doing something good but they're
they're bizarrely than protecting things
that would never protect them yeah
you're right and that's why you know
technically the title of my book should
have been how Western liberals empower
or inadvertently empower radicalism so
yeah they're not doing it on purpose but
they are doing it essentially if we did
look at how everybody just
attacked Mitt Romney for the fact that
he was Mormon do you know what I mean
like if we did take let's say a whole
bunch of Mormon symbols and had them
like if Nike put their swoosh on it and
if we had them on Reese's Pieces
commercials and in Banana Republic and
in Marks and Spencer and and you know
literally any flat surface
we just splashed all of these Mormon
symbols yeah all over the place people
would be responding appropriately right
people would be like why are you
celebrating Mormonism right why are we
valuing this far you know fundamentalist
ideology this that we shouldn't be I
don't even I don't even think they would
go that far I think most people would
say Mormons can be whoever they are and
do whatever they want but we just don't
need it to be promoted through all of
our means we don't need to slap our logo
on it yeah you know what I mean like
metallic create Mormon underwear for
Barbie right why would they create a
head job for Barbie that's what I'm
saying I'm not saying these people
aren't allowed to make whatever choices
they want to make or wear whatever they
want to wear I'm saying that we here as
you know free liberal enlightened
country you know of secularists we
really should not be celebrating
fundamentalist aspects of religion and
in fact I just want to add most Muslim
women in America do not wear hijab but
we're only celebrating the ones that
wear hijab mm-hmm Hillary Clinton
ignored the woman who won a gold medal
yep she ignored her and instead focused
on this woman over here because she has
a high jabba
so we it's very clear that we're not
celebrating American Muslim women in
general or just being inclusive of
different types of Americans we're
specifically supporting the American
women that look like fundamentalist
Muslims because they are wearing the
hijab those are the ones that get
celebrated those are the ones that get
on the cover of magazines those are the
ones that get splashed on every flat
surface so as all of this happens to you
and you write a book about this and you
enter the online world and the whole
thing we've talked a lot about this
privately what do you make of what's
happening broadly speaking on the right
that you're a woman you're brown you're
liberal you're supposed to be hated by
these people yeah if we listen to the
gist you know the non-thinking meme
that's out there but that's not really
the case no I mean I see a big
difference in just openness to diversity
of ideas so this long straight path that
I was talking about I see that very
clearly on the left but on the right you
know I can talk about the fact that I
don't believe in Christianity and I
don't believe in any religion and in
fact I think that it's toxic I can talk
about being pro-choice and I always will
be pro-choice and there's nothing you
can ever say to me that's going to ever
get me to consider not being pro-choice
I can that's a deal-breaker for a lot of
conservatives but they're still happy to
talk to you they're so happy to talk to
me because we agree on certain things
like we agree obviously the way we feel
about the left they agree with how I
feel about fundamentalist Islam but we
don't necessarily agree if we're gonna
be talking about fundamentalist
Christianity there are a lot of secular
people on the right that do agree with
me mm-hmm but what I mean to say is that
the variation in thought is more
accepted on the right than it is on the
left not the liberal classical liberal
not the typical left but that little far
left crazies over here there is no
variation in thought
like you need to speak perfectly you
can't even get a pronoun wrong where you
are just like evil right yeah but on the
right they're more willing to just sit
back and disagree with what I have to
say but but not try to shut me down or
not demonize me or not you know they
wouldn't call me gross and racist if I
had something to say that completely
disagreed with their value system or
with their belief system so as I said
that you know there are quite a few
people on the right on the far right who
I've interacted with who very you know
you know they'll get mad at me because I
have a white husband and we've made a
brown baby so I've now legs ruined that
lineage I get that kind of attacks
I get attacks for once the Muslim always
a Muslim we just don't want your type in
our country anyway go back to where you
came from so just like there are some
crazies on this side there are some
crazies on this side but I think that
this middle ground here is full of both
left and right people and that's like I
said to you when I was here a few years
ago I really believe that this is the
largest group but we just haven't found
a way to we're just not as loud like
these guys you know if it bleeds it
leads
yeah so these guys are loud and
obnoxious and so then they're getting
all the airtime but you know all the
rational people in the middle I think I
think we're the majority if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell